[Applause]
it's a great pleasure to be here and
really a great honor to be moderating
this panel with such an incredible
inspiring group of panelists I would
like to thank all of you for sharing
your wonderful work with us and also
thank our conference organizers for
bringing within this audience all of us
here together
so what I'll try to do now is to extract
some of the questions that were coming
up through the different presentations
and then use these questions to relate
them to some of the work done here
currently at MIT
well what does it mean to be material
today in the world experiencing and
existential crisis rapid depletion of
natural resources cultural conflicts and
social inequality it is within this both
local and global discussion about the
effects of unequal distribution of
wealth cultural and social diversity in
cities as well as the corporate
governance of Technology with our
panelists bring in their imaginative and
critical insight offering new avenues
for exploration critical reflections on
society but also really inspiring forms
for creation of alternatives
socio-political realities
situated in an intersection between art
cultural science and technology the work
of our panelists is compelling on so
many levels especially in the way
technology's engaged beyond pure techn
optimism and innovation rhetoric made
we're about to uncover a new material
logic for how we can meaningfully
identify and interact with the world
Lucy desired hussein's work on migration
displacement and isolation resonates
with some of that critical art and
design legacies of MIT for example the
interrogative design methodology of the
artist christopher gage code that you
see here former director of CBS who
shape the thinking of generations here
at MIT Media Lab the artists architects
engineers hippies alien stuff that
you've seen the slides is relevant today
as a cultural mediator embracing the
digital realm to translate the messages
that are recorded in these monitors that
you see and then the physical aspect of
this stick for the contemporary migrant
is in this little tube that you see
there where you can carry your memories
or whether they are smell or a material
will you and they help you come to terms
with your new cultural environment my
own body of work on the wearable mosques
for example is informed by this type of
thinking about art and design and the
form of interrogating cultural norms and
stereotypes as they are mediated through
digital images and deconstructing these
stereotypes through material and
transferable forms we live at a time
when wearing a veil a toolbar or other
culturally signifying headgear means
that one body can be perceived as a
threat the culturally rooted paranoia
and suspiciousness represent the type of
crisis that is everywhere and affecting
all of us and tomorrow March defines the
transcultural static the time developing
here aims to provide an understanding of
cultural differences as an opportunity
for creating a dialogue and empathy
between cultures it is inspiring to find
the same conversation being force within
our own scientific community at MIT for
example in the labs of Professor poles
or Cordero whose investigations of
complex network systems such as
microbial communities bring in new ideas
of our body is a ecosystem in which not
only our bacteria has socialized but
also in bacteria has conflict and also
it is taking care of each other our
panelists have also presented us with
their multifaceted explorations of the
body central to their exploration is the
concept of the second scale
and I would like to highlight three
layers of meanings that you maybe can
comment on in the discussion the first
regard the relationship between the self
the culture and Technology Media labs
researchers in Dakar for example is
exploring this relationship by creating
cultural technologies that hybridize the
materiality of the skin with the digital
technologies in service of self
expression and communication
the second dimension relates to the
sensing properties of the skin sensors
that have grown rather than manufactured
as in the case of the tangible media
biologic project that think the
biological and engineering approaches
using ancient of tyria that are known
from the Japanese not - preparation to
create a synthetic skin that extends the
idea of the skin both functionally and
symbolically we might then ask our
panelists here what does this merging of
the digital and material on the body
mean for you today how does it
constitute a new understanding of the
cells both on the level of the person so
individually and also socially what does
it mean for the collective where does
the control rest when you are sensing
yourself when you are creating these
feedback loops and projecting yourself
in various ways as we've seen from
Natasha's presentation today we have
very different forms and ideas of the
side work then we used to have and when
we were worried about the big
brother-type of control of surveillance
from above is today the notion of
control entirely internalized through
our system of self tracking the third
dimension of the second skin relates to
our imagination and perspective for the
future our panelists provide us with
visual imagery in material experiences
to envision possible avenues of human
evolution reproduction and the future of
the body this type of exploration
resonates with the biosuit professor
Dava Newman who works in NASA
to engineer active compressive
compression garments to allow for
increased mobility and survival in space
they also resonate with the work of
video lab professor Mary Oxman who take
such functional explorations into the
realm of art and fiction she uses
generative growth algorithms to
speculate on the future and explore how
we could redesign the relationship
between the most limited and the most
sophisticated life forms to augment our
biological functionality all the work we
have seen today interrogate the
relationship to our individual and
collective bodies by reinventing the
externalities and the internality of the
body through the wearable as an
interface between the cells and between
the collective in this new constantly
evolving space between the digital and
the material the body is linear
envisioned through flows of information
data and new sensing mechanisms in the
ways that we might develop anticipated
twenty years ago who st. Lucy's and
Cristina's work and here also the words
of Professor Skylar Tibbits expands the
material understanding of the body to
inquire pressing questions of the future
in relation to a rapidly changing
environment and new processes purposes
and ethics of Technology how do we
prepare the body to live in the 21st
century in 22nd century and 23rd century
what are the most pressing stakes for
you in your different disciplines and
practices how do we face extreme
situations ranging from climate exchange
sterilized environments life in outer
space or in culturally politically
psychologically blessed context on the
future versus thank you
[Applause]